welcome to Python tutorials with simpler
I'm Angela and today we look into the
if-else statement in Piketon so offense
is a decision making statement and there
are various formats of this so let's
begin and one by one we look at each of
these formats so the first one and the
most primitive form of the if-else
statement is the if statement here's the
syntax for if so you have the keyword if
followed by the condition and then we
have their double colons on the next
line you can put in your statements
which will be executed if this condition
results in true so all these statements
are indented slightly towards the right
this indicates that these statements are
within the if block so how exactly does
this if statement work let's look at the
flowchart to understand this so at first
we have the test expression or the
condition now if this condition results
in true that means any statements which
are inside the if block those will be
executed if this condition results in
false then the control of the program
will skip to these statements after the
if block and in either case the program
and precedes to print these statements
right after the if block so we'll better
understand this through an example I'll
move on to my jupiter notebook where
i'll demonstrate a code now i'll have a
variable a which is equal to the value
20 so i'll write an if statement the
keyword if followed by the condition and
my condition here is if a is greater
than 50 so if a is greater than 50 we
want to enter the if statement or the if
block and in here i'll print out this is
the if body and if a is not greater than
50 we would skip this entire part and
directly move on to this statement which
precedes the if block and here I'll have
the statement print this is outside the
if block so I'll run this program now so
in this particular case the value of a
was 20 which is obviously less than 50
which is why we did not enter the if
block we simply skip to the statement
after the if block now if I make the
value of a equal to 60 and then run the
program you see that we have entered the
if block
so this print statement here that is the
body so this print statement which says
this is the if body is printed and then
the control moves on to the next
statement which is outside the if block
which is this is outside the if block
so both these statements are printed
this is how if works so the next format
for F is the FL statement so so far we
could specify the statements that will
be executed if a condition is true now
in case of if else we can specify the
statements which will be executed in
case the condition is true and a
separate set of statements in case the
condition is false so that is the part
that comes and is now look at now let's
look at the syntax here this if followed
by the condition and then the double
colons just as before under which you
have your statements which will be
executed slightly indented to the right
and following the if block you have the
else block so if your condition results
in false the execution of the program
moves on to the else block and under the
else block again you have your
statements which will be slightly
indented to the right so here we will
have a look at the flowchart for the FL
statement if the test expression or the
condition results in true we move on to
the body of F and the statements within
this body of F will be executed after
which we'll move on to these statements
just below if if the condition initially
is false then we'll move on to the else
block and we'll have a separate set of
statements within the else block which
will be executed after which again we'll
move back to these statements just below
the F so again we have a demo here to
better understand how if-else works we
will print out if a number is odd or
even so initially I have a variable I
which is equal to 20 and then I'll have
the if statement and then I'll have the
if-else statement to check if I is odd
or even so I have I'm or true equal to
equal to zero so if I'm or two is equal
to zero that means the number is even
because I is completely divisible by two
so in that case I'll print out this is
the if block
and I is an even number and if I'm or
two is not equal to zero we need to
print out that I is odd so initially we
did not have this capability with just
if-statement but when you have the else
- if I'm or - is not zero the control
goes to the else statement and only
these statements which are inside the
else block gets printed so here I have
print this is the else block and then
print I is an odd number now let's run a
program so as we know 20 is an even
number so I'm or 2 results in 0 we go
inside the if statement and these two
statements get printed this is the if
block and I is an even number now I'll
change the value of I to 23 which is an
odd number so then these statements
inside the else block gets printed now
let's look at the nested-if
so nested-if is when you have an if
statement within an if statement this
kind of a situation often occurs when
you have to filter a variable multiple
times so let's look at the syntax for
nested if you have if followed by
condition and the double colon just as
before and now within the if statement
indented again to the right you'll have
this second condition so you'll have if
and your second condition which is
condition 2 followed by colons now you
can have as many levels of nesting as
required but of course the more number
of nestings you have the less optimized
the program is so you should always try
to minimize or if possible completely
avoid nested ifs now we look at a
flowchart for nested if you have your
first expression let's call this
expression 1 if this results in true
then the control moves on to this second
expression that is the nested if now if
this condition results in true you'll
have the execution for the body of if if
this condition results in false you will
have the execution for the body of else
now of course this else is not mandatory
you can either have an else statement or
completely avoid it altogether the
control however after else follows to
these statements right after the if
block now I'll move on to my jupiter
notebook to show yet another demo for
nested if so here i'll have a number and
first i need to filter this number as
- whether it's less than 25 or greater
than 25 if this number is greater than
25 then I need to also specify so here
I'll take an integer and my first filter
would be if the integer is less than or
greater than 25
if this integer is less than 25 I
further need to specify if this number
is even or odd and if the number is
greater than 25 I just need to print out
that yes this is greater than 25 so
let's begin I'll have a variable C and
for now I'll have the value 21 stored
and see now if C is less than 25 I'll
first check if C is an even number so if
C is less than 25 and then C mod 2 is
equal to equal to 0 I'll print out C is
an even number less than 25 C is an even
number less than 25 else that is if C
more 2 is not equal to 0 then I'll print
out C is an odd number less than 25
now if C is not less than 25 that is if
C is greater than 25 that would come
under the else block which matches with
our parent if statement so if you notice
the indentation here this else statement
which goes with this if statement is
indented at the same position and on the
other hand our parent if statement which
is paired with this else statement here
are indented at 0 with or the same
location so now under my parent error
statement I'll just print out C is
greater than 25
let me now run this program and see is
21 so it gets into this if statement
here because it's less than 25 and then
C more 2 which is 21 more 2 is not equal
to 0 so the control moves to this else
statement and C is an odd number less
than 25 gets printed if I had 50 here
run my program again this if statement
would not get executed control would
transfer to this else statement here and
C is greater than 25 gets printed now so
far with if and with if-else we had a
very binary approach that is if this
condition results in true print out the
statement aim if this results in false
print out statement B now what if we
have
other conditions for example we have a
number a and we need to check if a is
within the range one to Tim in which
case we need to print out that this
variable width is within the range 1 to
10 else if it's within the range 10 to
20 we need to print that out now if it's
in the range 20 to 30 we need to print
that out that is it's in the range 20 to
30 so in this case we cannot just stick
to if-else statement we need something
more
we need something which has more steps
and that is where if/elif/else ladder
comes into picture so here if we look at
the syntax we have your if condition
first the semicolons followed by your
statements and under this we do not
directly have the else statement but we
have another keyword the Elif so the
Elif statement lets you provide another
condition and not just go with the
faults of if so you have L it and then
condition 2 under which you have
statement now you can have any number of
Elif statements and finally you'll have
your L statement which will be executed
if none of the previous statements have
been executed so we'll have a look at
the flowchart to understand basically
how the if/elif/else ladder works you
have your first condition expression 1
if expression 1 results in true body of
if gets executed and immediately you
move on to the statement which is right
after the else statement if your
expression 1 results in false that means
any of the preceding l if or else
condition could result in true so the
program keeps checking all these
conditions so your next l if condition
is checked which is expression 2 and
then if expression 2 results in true
then the body of this LF statement is
executed and no further statements are
checked in the if/elif/else block
directly you move on to the statement
right after these blocks if none of the
previous Elif conditions or the if
conditions match the control moves on to
the L statement and the l statement will
definitely get executed so once the else
statement is executed the control moves
to these statements which are right
after the if LM else block so that is
how the control flows in if/elif/else
ladder we'll have a look at another
to better understand this so here I'll
have a variable say Val which stores a
single alphabet which is 4 now Z and
then I'll have the if/elif/else ladder
to check if this variable or if this
value is stored within the variable is a
vowel or a consonant moreover with
specific bubble it is so first I have if
by equal to equal to 8 print this is a
bubble and print this is the bubble a
now we have 5 consonants that's a e i o
u so we cannot directly go with an else
statement here we need to check the
condition for each of these alphabets or
these roubles so now I'll have the LF
where equal to e print this is the
bubble e just copy/paste this L if again
the step for I
then four oh you and finally if your
variable is not equal to any of these
five letters then we just print out that
it's a consonant so that can come in the
else part so if none of these statements
on top execute the control directly
comes to else statement and else
definitely gets executed so here we will
print out this is a consonant before I
run this program a small correction it
should be double equal to single equal
to is used for assignment okay now we
can run this code and it prints out this
is a consonant so val healthy value Z
which is of course a consonant I'll put
in a vowel now say Oh run the code again
and rinse out this is a bubble oh so
this works perfectly fine so now that we
have looked at the various forms of F
let's start with some exercises so first
we'll have a program to find the
greatest of three numbers of course we
can use the max function for this it's a
one line quote but will not do that here
we actually type out a program for it
now this is a very typical example of
how you can use the if Elif ladder so
I'll have three variables a equal to 10
B equal to 15 and C equal to 20 now my
first of condition would be if a is
greater than B and a is greater than C
now if a is greater than both B and C
obviously E is the greatest number the
greatest number is a l if so the
condition for that would be if B is
greater than a and B is greater than C
in which case we'll print out the
greatest number is B and finally if
neither a or b are the greatest numbers
then obviously it's C and that we can
just put down in the L statement the
greatest number is C now in this program
we have not considered if two of the
numbers or maybe all three of them are
equal since the whole point of this
exercise is to check your if-else
concepts or to understand them better
let's ignore that part for now run this
code and the greatest number is C which
is obvious C is 20 so what happens here
is the control first goes to the first
if statement and checks a is great
than B now if a is greater than B then
only will it proceed to check if a is
greater than C so that's the thing with
the ant statement for this if condition
to be true both the right hand and the
left hand side of ant should result in
true so if the first condition that is a
greater than B results in false then the
statement won't even check if a is
greater than C or not now if a is
greater than both of them you have the
greatest number is a now if statement
does not result in true which in our
case it won't it moves on to the Elif
statement if B is greater than a and B
is greater than C then the greatest
number is B again in our particular
situation here Elif also results in
false and the control moves on to the
else statement and it prints the L
statement so the else statement in the
case of if/elif/else ladder is like the
default statement in case of switch I
hope that helps you understand this
better now we can do the same program
using nested if so how is that done so
here I'll have a variable a a which is
equal to say 350 may be equal to 250 and
C C which is equal to 300 now my first
if statement will check if a a is
greater than B B so a a greater than V B
now if a a is greater than B B will
check if a a is greater than C C so that
would be a nested if and if a a is
greater than B B and a a is greater than
C C which is the nested part then within
this I can print out that a a is the
greatest number a a and if this is not
the case that is if a second if
statement does not result in true we
have nothing to print it means that a is
somewhere between B and C and we do not
need to print this so directly we will
move on to the Elif that pairs up with
our outside if and I will refer to a a
BB and CC as ABC so LF b is greater than
C now under this if B is greater than C
I need to check if B is greater than a 2
now under this if B is greater than C I
need to check if B is greater than a 2
so I'll have a nested if under this Elif
where I'll check if
is greater than aim and if both of these
statements result in true we can't say
that B is the greatest number we have so
BB is the greatest number and finally if
this if statement or this ellipse
statement did not result in true then
we'll have an else statement here which
will definitely be executed and this
would print out that C is the greatest
number so here we do not need a nested
if statement because of course if the
previous two statements did not result
in true else will which will say CC is
the greatest number so this our program
this the same as the above program to
find the largest of the three numbers
but here we have used it nested if now a
small modification I can make here is
instead of printing out the variable
name you can also print out the value
which is stored within the variable so
just go with percentile D is the
greatest number and percentile D will
then be your placeholder over here so
after the codes you can just put in your
variable name a a and same here case of
C C have your integer placeholder and
the variable we are now ready to run
this program so it prints out correctly
350 is the greatest number which is the
value stored in a so a very first if
statement itself resulted in true moved
on to the nested if statement again a a
was greater than C C so that two
resulted in true and this print
statement here is what got executed so
you can also have print statements in
between your if statement and the nested
if statement for example here I can have
a print statement which prints out that
a is greater than B B so I can see
percentile D is greater than percentile
D and these two placeholders will hold
the values of the variables a and B B
and this is how you do that so run my
code now small arrow there is no comma
here so as you see when this print
statement gets executed it does not
destroy the flow of your nested if now
we'll have one last exercise here we
need to print out if a number is
divisible by 2 3 or 5 so I'll have a
variable say D which is equal to 15
initially
of course I can take this from the user
too and I need to check if D mod 2 is
equal to zero so D mod 2 equal to equal
to zero if that is true then I can print
out that D is divisible by two so I'll
say it is divisible by two now L if D
mod three equal to equal to zero so if
it's not divisible by two is it
divisible by three I'll print out it is
divisible by three
L if if it's not divisible by three is
it divisible by five if so I'll print
out it is divisible by five and if none
of this works out I'll have an else
statement printing out the number is not
divisible by two three or five so at
first look this program seems to work
fine now here's the problem the very
default value that we have taken 15 is
divisible by both three and five now the
problem with if/elif/else ladder is that
if this if statement results in true it
will not check any of these further
conditions it will directly skip to the
statement that follows this entire
ladder block so if suppose our value was
twelve
if D more two so 12 more two will result
in zero and it will print out this is
divisible by two and then it'll skip all
the other Elif or L statements will run
this code and as you see here it's just
printed divisible by two but 12 is also
divisible by three so in this kind of a
situation what we do is we do not go
with the if/elif/else ladder because
that will not work here we instead just
go with the if statement so if you just
go with the simple if statement even if
the statement results in true the
program will still check this next if
statement so we say if D more two is
equal to zero we'll print out it is
divisible by two
if D more three is equal to zero we'll
print out its divisible by three and the
same thing with five now if it's not
divisible by any of these three we need
to print out that the number is not
divisible by two three or five now
here's another problem so this L stay
a trend here is coupled with this if
statement if this if statement results
in shoe this L statement will not be
printed which works perfectly fine
because if the number is divisible by 5
we just need to print out that it is
divisible by 5 but what if the number is
not divisible by 5 then automatically
the control comes to this else statement
here and this statement gets printed now
that is the very case if we take D as 12
see I run this code here and D mod 2 is
equal to 0 so the statement it is
divisible by 2 gets executed again it is
divisible by 3 gets executed but D mod 5
is not equal to 0
this makes the else statement executes
and this executed the number is not
divisible by 2 3 or 5 which is wrong
because our number is divisible by 2 & 3
so now we need a slightly different
approach so what we do here is we'll
introduce a counter variable count which
is equal to 0 now every time a number is
divisible by 2 3 or 5 will increment
count so count plus equal to 1 now this
is the same as writing count equal to
count plus 1 this is a shorthand and
similarly if D mod 3 is equal to 0 I'll
increment here - I'll have an increment
and here I will not have the else
statement but instead I'll say if count
is equal to equal to 0 then you print
out the statement that it is not
divisible by 2 3 or 5 let's run this
code now and see how it works just fine
so 12 is divisible by 2 it is divisible
by 3 we'll go with another number 15
divisible by 3 and 5 so if I go with 7
run the code the number is not divisible
by 2 3 or 5 so I hope you understood how
if-else or just the if statement or the
if/elif/else ladder works also the
nested if if you have any doubts please
post them in the comment section below
and we'll definitely get back to you if
you like this video please hit the like
button also subscribe to our channel if
you have not yet as we have a lot more
great videos coming up for you so stay
tuned and I'll see y'all next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here